Who lives the longest and why?
Let’s take a look at the top 10 countries
with the healthiest citizens, based on a variety
of factors and find out exactly what they’re
doing right.
10.
First up with a life expectancy of 81.5 years
is the Netherlands.
The Netherlands is widely regarded to offer
one of the highest standards of living in
the world.
This is largely due to the countries’ relatively
low food prices and a diet that places emphasis
on vegetables, fruit and dairy products.
A popular and highly nutritious meal in the
Netherlands is a Dutch Pea Soup called Snert,
stuffed full of vegetables.
9.
At 9 is Canada.
Amazingly Canada has one of the lowest number
of doctors per capita of any country in this
video.
With only 2.1 doctors for every 1,000 citizens.
Yet Canadians enjoy one of the highest life
expectancies in the world at an average of
82.5 years.
8.
At 8 is Australia, with a life expectancy
of 83.
Australians have one of the best health care
systems in the world.
Down under, insurance companies are required
to charge policyholders the exact same premium,
regardless of their age, gender or history.
Meaning no matter who you are or what you’ve
done you will pay the same as everyone else
for your health insurance.
7.
At 7 is Switzerland, the Swiss have a life
expectancy of 82.8.
The Swiss healthcare system has been named
the best in the world on many occasions.
Naturally this helps, but the Swiss are also
lucky enough to be nestled right in the heart
of the Alps which means sports such as hiking
and skiing are prevalent, helping to keep
the Swiss people fit and healthy all year
round.
6.
At 6 is Germany.
Germans pay handsomely for their healthcare.
11.3% of the country’s GDP is spent on healthcare.
There is no waiting for appointments in Germany
and until very recently you didn’t even
have to pay for your taxi ride to the hospital.
5.
At 5 is Finland.
This may come as a surprise, because 35 years
ago Finland was one of the world’s unhealthiest
nations.
And the country actually held the global record
for the highest numbers of heart disease.
But this shocked the Finnish Government into
action.
The Government launched a full blown campaign
to dramatically improve people’s health
by encouraging an active lifestyle and promoting
fruit and vegetable intake.
And it worked, present day Finland is a very
different place and rates of cardiovascular
heart disease have since dropped by over 65%.
4.
at 4 is Sweden.
Sweden can owe most of it’s success to an
emphasis on staying active.
The Swedish government invests a lot of money
in building new cycle routes and encouraging
people to get out of their cars and cycle
instead.
Some Swedish GPs even give patients “exercise
on prescription”.
Sweden also has one of the lowest air pollution
rates in the world.
3.
At 3 is Iceland.
With all the countries beautiful mountains,
glaciers, volcanoes, and waterfalls it’s
no surprise that the Icelandic love to spend
plenty of time enjoying the great outdoors.
But the main reason Iceland is so high on
this list is because they eat practically
zero processed food, choosing to eat exclusively
locally grown food, even their organic food
is considerably less processed than in the
US and UK, Icelandic food is considered by
many to be the purest on the planet.
People don’t buy their produce from industrial
farms in Iceland, they instead buy from local
family farms.
The country has a strong lineage of hunting,
fishing and foraging, it’s what’s sustained
Iceland for centuries, and to a large extent
still does to this day.
And to top it off Iceland is also one of the
least polluted countries in the world.
2.
At 2 is Japan.
Japan has been considered for many years to
be the world’s healthiest country.
Obesity is virtually non-existent in the country.
And they owe it to the Japanese tradition
of exercising strict portion control and eating
a wide variety of foods.
The Japanese also choose the right foods to
eat, such as nutrient-rich soy and they are
one of the world’s largest consumers of
omega-3 rich fish.
A typical meal in Japan consists of up to
six teacup-sized portions of different foods,
and a lot of vegetables.
The Japanese aim to eat at 30-40 different
things every day, so they get a large variety
of nutrients and vitamins.
Seaweed is also a major component in the Japanese
diet, highly regarded by the Japanese for
its health properties.
Up to 6 varieties of seaweed are eaten every
day by the average Japanese citizen.
The Japanese enjoy a life expectancy of 84.6.
1.
At 1 is Okinawa Island.
Okay it’s not actually a country, it’s
a small island belonging to Japan, south of
the Japanese mainland.
Okinawa Island has the highest percentage
of centenarians, that’s people over 100
years old, of anywhere in the world.
It’s considered by many to be the healthiest
place in the world.
They share the same healthy diet of fish,
rice and vegetables as the rest of Japan,
but the Okinawans, have another ace up their
sleeves, they claim the biggest reason for
their longevity is their happiness and lack
of stress.
A lot of elderly in the West are struggling
to survive on small pensions with physical
pains and find the whole process of ageing
generally quite stressful.
But not the Okinawans, they stay active even
at 100 plus and have a child-like zeal towards
life, stress just doesn’t seem to exist
on Okinawa Island.